the RCN the Royal College of Nursing has
released a statement and it says this
this from Pat Cullen the the general
secretary saying the government was true
to its word they would not talk to me
about pay I needed to come out of this
meeting with something serious to show
nurses why they should not strike this
week remember the strikes are planned in
England and Wales for this Thursday
regret regrettably they are not getting
an extra Penny ministers had too little
to say and I had to speak at length
about the unprecedented strength of
feeling in the profession I expressed my
deep disappointment at the belligerence
they have closed their books and walked
away well that from pack Allen General
Secretary of the Royal College of
Nursing on those last Stitch they've
been called last-ditch talks between
them and the government between the
health secretary Steve Barkley and
absolutely nothing to show forward
according into Pat Cullen there
particularly these are that word
belligerence so they've closed the books
and walked away so the strikes certainly
the strike this week goes ahead